Your agent is about to infiltrate
a life or death poker game
in a hidden back room of the grand casino.
You’re on the trail of an elite society
of assassins,
each of whom carries a signature
playing card corresponding to their role.
You’ve received intel from a 100% reliable
source about how they operate.
Their M.O. is to invite their victims
to a high stakes game
with one or more killers at the table.
The game is a variant of poker
played with a single, fair deck
where every player receives
two cards in secret.
Each assassin immediately and covertly
swaps one of the cards
they’ve been fairly dealt
with their signature card.
Then the robo-dealer reveals
three shared cards on the table.
After betting, the assassins play
their signature cards
as a signal that they’re ready.
When the last one comes out,
they go about their grim business.
Today's game is no different,
and your mission is to identify the
assassins and save all the victims.
Everyone at the table is either
an assassin or a victim,
and there must be at least one of each.
The game is about to begin when
your agent finds the secret passage
and talks her way into a seat
at the table.
Meanwhile, you’re monitoring
the proceedings with an insect drone.
If you can figure out who has swapped
out a fairly dealt card with a new one,
you can identify the assassins
and alert your agent through her earpiece.
The game begins.
Your drone doesn’t catch
anyone’s sleight of hand,
but it does manage to get a look
at the cards each player holds.
Suddenly — disaster.
Someone swats the drone,
breaking your video feed
before the reveal of the shared cards.
It goes into emergency mode
and is just operational enough
to send the following string of data
about those three shared cards
before shutting down for good.
And that’s it; you’ve lost
your eyes and ears in the room.
Your spy can’t see anyone else’s cards
or tell you anything,
so it’s up to you to figure this out,
and fast.
Who are the assassins?
Pause here to figure it out yourself.
Answer in 3
Answer in 2
Answer in 1
You can start by combining
the first two rules.
The second tells us that there
are at least two queens,
and the first that there's
at least one king.
So we must have two queens and a king.
The first rule then tells us that the king
is either in the middle or the left.
That’s all we can do for now,
so let’s look at the suits.
By the same logic, we know that there
must be two spades and one heart.
And by the third rule, that heart must
be in the middle or on the right.
We can now make a table
with our four possibilities.
We can eliminate this one,
because it would require the deck
having two queens of spades.
We can’t rule out any other options,
but we don’t actually need to;
in every case, the three cards are the
king of spades, the queen of hearts,
and the queen of spades,
in different orders.
And it just so happens that each
of these players holds one of those cards.
So, they’re the assassins, right?
Well, hold on, there’s something odd.
Player 2 and the agent both hold
the same card.
So, one of those must be
a signature assassin card.
But you know from your Intel that there’s
at least one victim who is not the agent.
How can that be?
Oh, no.
There’s only one possibility:
your spy is the assassin known
as the king of diamonds,
and she’s been playing you
this whole time.
The only victim is player 2.
You rush in, grab hold of player 2
just before the bidding ends,
and make a run for it.
On your way out, you lock eyes
with your backstabbing partner.
You search her features, desperate for
any sign of remorse or apology.
All you get back is a poker face.